ja nur die sache ist ganz einfach was
mich richtig traurig macht also ich habe
mich wirklich heftig darauf gefreut
hey was geht ab bereits willkommen beim
neuen video ja eigentlich ist dieses
video vielleicht so muss ich nicht
unbedingt machen aber mir ist einfach
sooo langweilig und ich hab gerade bock
irgendwas zu filmen deswegen habe ich
jetzt ein bisschen was mir gerade
passiert ist und was mich so aufregt man
das ist einfach ich denke mir so man
warum habe ich denn so viel pech warum
kann es sich irgendwie anders passieren
weil gut das ist es so gekommen wie es
gekommen ist und ich hier im krankenhaus
ja das hier ist mein zimmer wie man
sieht ich werde dir wirklich top
unterhalten neben mir liegt die
franziska da drüben liegt hubert und
dort hinten liegt ja fast
und ja mit denen es echt jedes gespräch
super nein wir kommen mal kurz auf den
punkt auf jeden fall
letzte nacht eine bin ich aufgewacht und
ich hatte heftige bauchschmerzen es
waren die bauchschmerzen meines lebens
ehrlich hat schon acht jahre oder so
keine bauchschmerzen mehr wenn dann
irgendwann ins krankenhaus gefahren
arbeiten die sofort muss leider dein
blinddarm raus und ich wurde wirklich
ganz früher schon mal operiert aber
irgendwie jetzt die letzten jahre nie
und ich hatte schon ein bisschen schiss
aber alles gut verlaufen
danke an meinen arzt du bist der king
auch wenn ich mehr weiß wie du heißt ja
nur die sache ist ganz einfach was mich
richtig traurig macht also ich hab mich
wirklich kräftig drauf gefreut
ich und meine freunde wir werden noch
nehmen meine freunde und ich nur der
trainer immer zum schluss auf jeden fall
wir werden auch in den urlaub geflogen
morgen für eine woche und ich habe mich
wirklich richtig darauf gefreut weil
noch mal urlaub ich hab grad richtig
lust auf urlaub und genau jetzt wirklich
genau jetzt ich denke mir sowas kann
doch nicht sein man kann es sich vor
einer woche passieren oder meinetwegen
auch in zwei wochen aber doch nicht
jetzt einen tag bevor ich eigentlich im
urlaub wird passiert jetzt das und jetzt
muss ich bis mittwoch glaube ich hier
rumgammeln und kann einfach nichts
machen außer fernsehen gucken
ich bin schon so verzweifelt ich hab
schon meinem fernseher diesem heftigen
flatscreen da namen gegeben weil es
einzige da mit mir spricht dass philipp
übrigens ja aber ich habe einfach
gedacht wenn ich jetzt schon hier bin
und mich langweile kann ich auch ab und
zu mal irgendwas für euch filmen was
vielleicht ein bisschen interessant ist
oder mir spaß macht darum geht es ja in
erster linie ich habe der verlust auf
youtube und ich vermisse es schon
irgendwie
naja ich gucke jetzt noch fernsehen wir
sehen uns morgen philipp was sagst du
dazu alles klar philipp dankeschön für
deinen kommentar guten morgen leute
haben wir auf jeden fall bin ich gerade
hier draußen
hier geht's eigentlich schon wieder ganz
gut ich hab mein girlfriend am start
auf jeden fall waren so langweilig wir
sind hier in diesem park reingegangen
und haben ein musical gemacht einen
neuen link dazu ist in der video
beschreibung könnt ihr euch ja mal
reinziehen uns da folgen also bei musik
nämlich sie ab und zu mal mit rein soll
ich finde youtube ist doof weil das geht
immer ein bisschen in die privatsphäre
aber musical ist okay ich melde mich
vielleicht später noch mal keine ahnung
er ist gerade glaube ich halb elf und
morgen darf ich nicht gehen so scheiße
langweilig und so heftige sachen
passiert die musste ich auf jeden fall
erzählen deswegen wenn ihr bottroper
könnt ihr gerne doch nach oben da lassen
ansonsten keine ahnung ich mich morgen
abend melde das passiert ich hoffe die
gründe zu finden
jojo das war schlecht auf jeden fall bin
ich jetzt wieder zu hause ja leute ich
bin richtig froh wieder hier zu sein
jetzt schon ein schönes thema mein
laptop und ich wollte euch noch schnell
was sagen wie gesagt erst mal ich bin
wieder zu hause noch eine info ich
glaube das hat sich gestern auch schon
mal gesagt ich weiß allerdings nicht es
im krankenhaus eine sache passiert wo
ich dachte mädels ist es euer erz das
könnt ihr doch nicht machen
das ist wirklich richtig lustige story
deswegen wenn ihr bock drauf habe dass
ich die euch morgen erzählt dann kommt
das video dazu morgen so gegen 18 uhr
könnt mir gerne daumen nach oben da
lassen und das in die kommentare
schreiben dann sehe ich das jahr und an
sonst würde ich sagen weißt du doch die
video der ist da bin ich auch am start
ich kapiere von und mit alten ganz alten
autogrammkarten noch 200 stück wie kann
ich euch mal zeigen deswegen ich freue
mich darauf folgt dürfen zusammen